♪ ♪
>> Tucker: PRESIDENT OBAMA
SPOKE AT MIT ON FRIDAY, AND
IMMEDIATELY BEGAN REWRITING
HISTORY.
HE MADE THE CLAIM THAT HAS
ADMINISTRATION WAS SCANDAL FREE,
THANKS TO THE MAGICAL POWER OF
DIVERSITY.
RUNNING GUNS TO MEXICAN CARTELS
DIDN'T HAPPEN.
WEAPONIZING THE IRS AND THE FBI
AGAINST POLITICAL OPPONENTS,
FAKE NEWS.
WHILE OBAMA HAS BEEN PATTING
HIMSELF ON THE BACK, THE PARTY
HE SHATTERS SEARCHING FOR A
CHAMPION IN THE NEXT ELECTION.
FOX'S JUAN WILLIAMS JUST ARGUED
THAT THE THREE STRONGEST
CHALLENGES WOULD ALL BE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN WOMEN, OPRAH,
MICHELLE OBAMA,
SENATOR KAMALA HARRIS OF
CALIFORNIA.
IS IT TRUE?
BRIT HUME JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
IS IT TRUE?
DO YOU THINK DIVERSITY KEPT
BARACK OBAMA'S TWO TERMS
ENTIRELY SCANDAL FREE?
>> I DON'T THINK IT WAS ENTIRELY
SCANDAL FREE.
YOU JUST MENTIONED A COUPLE OF
EXAMPLES AND THERE'S ANOTHER
ONE, KIND OF A HOWLER, HIS
SECRETARY OF STATE SO RECKLESSLY
MISHANDLED CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION THAT SHE WAS VERY
NEARLY INDICTED IN MANY LEGAL
EXPERTS THINK SHE SHOULD HAVE
BEEN.
I WOULD RATE THAT IS A BIG
SCANDAL.
I DON'T THINK DIVERSITY HAD
ANYTHING TO DO WITH IT ONE WAY
OR ANOTHER.
IT CERTAINLY ARGUES AGAINST THE
IDEA THAT IT WAS SCANDAL FREE.
IT WASN'T.
>> Tucker: IT'S FUNNY, THOUGH.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT -- AND TO
HIS CREDIT, HE HASN'T BEEN --
THIS WAS AN OFF THE RECORD
COMMENT THAT GOT REPORTED.
HE HASN'T BEEN IN THE NEWS
REALLY COME AND I THINK THAT IS
EXACTLY WHAT A FORMER PREVACID
AND SHOULD BE COMING OUT AROUND.
HOWEVER, IT SEEMS A LITTLE EARLY
TO BE REWRITING THE HISTORY OF
ADMINISTRATION I JUST ENDED.
DOESN'T IT?
>> ALL PRESIDENTS TRY TO SEE
THEIR ADMINISTRATIONS OF THE
MOST FAVORABLE POSSIBLE LIGHT
AND HE IS LOOKING BACK ON HIS
AND I'M SURE HE'S LOOKING AT THE
MAN IN THE WHITE HOUSE AND
TRYING TO CREATE A CONTRAST WITH
HIM, BECAUSE OBAMA, WHETHER YOU
LIKE THEM OR NOT, DID BEHAVE
HIMSELF WITH A CERTAIN DIGNITY
AND GRACE THAT SOME HAVE FOUND
LACKING IN DONALD TRUMP, CLEARLY
OBAMA HAS FOUND IT LACKING A
DONALD TRUMP, BUT I THINK HE
WOULD LIKE TO CONTRAST HIS
PERFORMANCE IN OFFICE WITH THAT
OF MR. TRUMP.
TO SAY THAT HAS ADMINISTRATION
WAS SCANDAL FOR HIS NONSENSE.
>> Tucker: IT IS.
THERE WAS A PIECE BY OUR
COLLEAGUE AND FRIEND
JUAN WILLIAMS, A LOT OF PEOPLE
HAVE WRITTEN THIS, SAID THAT THE
THREE MAIN CHALLENGERS TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP, WHO ANNOUNCED
HE IS RUNNING AGAIN THREE YEARS
FROM NOW, WOULD BE OPRAH,
MICHELLE OBAMA, AND
KAMALA HARRIS OF CALIFORNIA, ALL
THREE BLACK WOMEN.
WHAT STRUCK ME ABOUT THIS WAS
THE WAY IT WAS FRAMED IN THE WAY
SO MANY OF THESE CONVERSATIONS
ARE FRAMED.
THEY PRIMARILY TURN ON QUESTIONS
OF RACE AND GENDER.
IS THAT THE FUTURE OF AMERICAN
POLITICS?
IDENTITY POLITICS?
>> MATURES THE FUTURE FUTURE OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY LOOKS AT THINGS THAT WAY.
BEING A WOMAN AND A MINORITY
WOULD BE AN IMPORTANT CREDENTIAL
FOR A NOMINATION IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
IT DOESN'T MEAN HE WILL GET THE
NOMINATION, BUT IT GIVES YOU A
LEG UP.
IT GAVE HILLARY CLINTON A LEG UP
AND ENABLED HER TO FIGHT OFF THE
RATHER SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE
FROM A GERIATRIC SOCIALIST AND
THE PERSON OF BERNIE SANDERS.
WHAT MIGHT HAVE THOUGHT THAT
WOULD BE EASY BUT SUCH IS THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
IT WASN'T EASY AT ALL.
LOOKING AHEAD TO 2020, WHOEVER
IT IS, IS LIKELY TO HAVE QUITE A
LEFTIST CREDENTIALS IN ORDER TO
TOUCH THE HEART OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, WHICH IS FAR
TO THE LEFT OF WHERE IT USED TO
BE.
ALL THREE OF THE WOMEN
DESCRIBED, I'M NOT SURE WHERE
OPRAH IS ON THE ISSUES COME I
HAVEN'T LOOKED INTO IT CAREFULLY
BECAUSE I DOUBT SHE WILL RUN.
KAMALA HARRIS HAS SHOWN HERSELF
TO BE QUITE LIBERAL, AND
CERTAINLY MICHELLE OBAMA WOULD
BE SEEN IN THAT LIGHT, AS WELL.
I THINK KAMALA HARRIS, BY THE
WAY, WOULD BE AN INTERESTING
CANDIDATE.
SHE HAS A TENDENCY TO MAKE
ABSENCE A PARTICULARLY AMAZING
THINGS.
SHE SAID THAT JOE ARPAIO SHOULD
NOT HAVE BEEN PARDONED BECAUSE
HE COMMITTED A CRIME.
BADHAM, THAT IS WHY HE NEEDED TO
BE PARDONED.
SHE ALSO SAID THAT IT WAS WRONG
TO SAY THAT THE DREAMERS WERE
UNLAWFUL.
THAT IS PART OF THE DEFINITION
OF WHERE THE DREAMERS ARE.
THEY CAME HERE AND ARE HERE
ILLEGALLY.
THAT IS WHY WE ARE TRYING TO --
SO MANY PEOPLE ARE WORKING HARD
TO TRY TO FIND A WAY TO KEEP
THEM HERE.
THEY WOULDN'T BE SUBJECT TO
DEPORTATION IF THEY WEREN'T
UNLAWFUL.
SUCH AS KAMALA HARRIS.
I THINK MICHELLE OBAMA, TUCKER,
WOULD BE AN OPPOSING CANDIDATE.
>> Tucker: INTERESTING.
CAN WE BE TOTALLY HONEST AND SAY
THAT TERRY McAULIFFE, MAKING
NOISES ABOUT RUNNING THE OTHER
DAY, A NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO LOOK
LIKE TERRY McAULIFFE, SAYING
THEY WILL RUN AS A DEMOCRAT,
NOBODY LIKE TERRY McAULIFFE
WILL GET THE NOMINATION THIS
TIME?
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
I THINK TERRY McAULIFFE WOULD
PROBABLY BE SEEN AS TOO MUCH OF
A CREATURE OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY AS IT ONCE WAS UNDER
BILL CLINTON AND LATER UNDER
HILLARY CLINTON.
I DON'T THINK THAT IS FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS RIGHT NOW.
DIANNE FEINSTEIN, WHO IS NOT A
LIBERAL ON EVERYTHING BUT A
LIBERAL ON NEARLY EVERYTHING,
WAS JUST DENIED THE ENDORSEMENT
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND DAN LIPINSKI, A CONGRESSMAN
FROM THE SOUTHWEST SIDE OF
CHICAGO, WHOSE DISTRICT INCLUDES
THE SUBURBS, WAS JUST GIVEN THE
HEAVE BY THE DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSIONAL CAMPAIGN COMMITTEE
IN HIS REELECTION BID IN
FAVOR OF A MORE LIBERAL
CANDIDATE.
THIS IS WHERE THAT PARTY IS
COMING, AND IF YOU WILL WIN IT
NOMINATION IN THIS PARTY IN 2020
IN MY ESTIMATION, YOU HAVE TO BE
PRETTY FAR OUT THERE.
IF YOU ARE ELIZABETH WARREN, YOU
MIGHT HAVE THE CREDENTIALS, YOU
MIGHT NOT HAVE THE RIGHT TO SKIN
COLOR.
MICHELLE OBAMA MIGHT INDEED FIT
THE BILL.
>> Tucker: I THINK IT'S BEEN